Dear fellow scholars.
This is two minute papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér. The promise of virtual, yeah,
Reality. VR is indeed truly incredible.
If one day it comes to fruition.
Doctors could be trained to perform surgery in a virtual environment.
We could train better pilots with better flight simulators,
expose astronauts to virtual zero gravity simulations.
You name it an important part of doing many of these is simulating
walking in a virtual environment. You'll see, we can be located in a small room,
put on a VR headset and enter a wonderful, expensive virtual world.
However, as we start walking, we immediately experience a big problem.
What is that problem? Well,
we bumped into things as a remedy. We could make our virtual world smaller,
but that would defeat the purpose.
This earlier technique addresses this walking problem spectacularly by
redirection. So what is this redirection thing? Exactly.
Redirection is a simple concept that changes our movement in the virtual world.
So it deviates from our real path in the room in a way that both lets us
explore the virtual world and not bump into walls and objects. In reality,
in the meantime here, you can see how the blue and orange lines deviate,
which means that the algorithm is at work, who it is.
We can wonder about in a huge and majestic virtual landscape or a cramped
bar, even when being confined to a small physical room,
loving the idea,
but there is more to interacting with virtual worlds than walking. For instance,
look at this tech demo that requires more precise hand movements.
How do we perform these? Well, the key is here, controllers.
Clearly they work, but can we get rid of them?
Can we just opt for a more natural solution and use our hands instead?
Well,
hold onto your papers because this new work uses a learning based algorithm to
teach a head mounted camera, to tell the orientation of our hands at all times,
of course the quality of the execution matters a great deal.
So we have to ensure at least three things.
One is that the hand tracking happens with minimal latency,
which means that we see our actions immediately with minimal delay
too. We need low jitter,
which means that the key points of the reconstructed hand should not change too
much from frame to frame. This happens a great deal with previous methods.
And what about the new one? Oh yes.
Much smoother.
Check Mark note that the new method also remembers the history of the hand
movement and therefore can deal with difficult occlusion situations.
For instance, look at the pinky here.
The previous technique would not know what's going on with it,
but this new one knows exactly what is going on because it has information on
what the hand was doing a moment ago. And three,
this needs to work in all kinds of lighting conditions.
Let's see if it can reconstruct arrange of mythical creatures in poor lighting
conditions. Yes,
these docks are reconstructed just as well as the mighty postmaster
and D scissors to Bravo. So what can we do with this?
A great deal. For instance,
we can type on a virtual keyboard or implement all kinds of virtual user
interfaces that we can interact with. We can also organize imaginary boxes
and of course we can't leave out the two minute papers,
favorite going into a physics simulation and playing with it.
But of course not, everything is perfect here. Look, hand,
hand interactions don't work so well.
So folks who prefer virtual reality applications that include the washing,
our hands should look elsewhere, but of course, one step at a time.
This episode has been supported by Lambda GPU cloud.
If you're looking for inexpensive cloud GPU's for AI,
check out Lambda GPU cloud,
they recently launched Quadro RTX 6,000 RTX,
8,000 and V 100 instances and hold onto your papers
because Lambda GPU cloud can cost less than half of AWS
and Azure.
Plus they are the only cloud service with 48 gigabyte RTX eight thousands
joined researchers at organizations like Apple, MIT,
and Caltech in using Lambda cloud instances, workstations or servers,
make sure to go to Lambda labs.com/papers to sign up for one of their
amazing GPU instances today.
Our thanks to Lambda for the longstanding support and for helping us make better
videos for you. Thanks for watching and for your generous support.
And I'll see you next time.